[Musique]
aladdin et jasmine ne sont pas du voyage
mais avec son manège du contrevent la
compagnie grande et douglas proposer une
pause aériennes et poétiques
wes pour un peu d' imaginaires s'est
inquiété un décor avec pas mal de livres
2 qui invite au voyage c'est
qu'improviser pour pour des questions
aussi technique que ce que je sais
jamais quand le manège va vraiment
s'arrêter donc je ne pourrais pas faire
un morceau déjà écrit et et puis c'est
beaucoup plus plaisant pour moi dans un
premier temps en fonction de ce qui
c'était très agréable la fin vraiment
tout doux avec la musique bonne
expérience de sympa la commanderie a
multiplié atelier rendez vous pour son
temps forts de cette quinzaine décalé
pour cette nouvelle édition le marché
des associations solidaires et créateurs
locaux étaient à nouveau proposées 650
personnes se sont laissé séduire le
samedi 11 décembre
les créneaux de patinoires sont complets
les ateliers sont complets les artisans
et créateurs sont contents de
l'affluence proposer des ateliers qui
sont bas justement un petit peu décalé
qui sont pas forcément l'atelier
traditionnelle qu'on pourrait attendre
pour noël pour préparer noël mais qui
nous servent aussi à préparer noël le
noël décalé a pris fin ce mercredi 15
décembre
la magie de l'avent continue patience
plus que quelques jours avant le
réveillon
[Musique]